[Music]
[Applause]
kevin james we spoke to him on monday so
i did not ask him about sean payton
stepping down as the saints head coach
because that just happened but uh as i
mentioned the movie it's called home
team it'll be released on netflix
tomorrow two years after winning the
super bowl sean payton gets suspended
goes back to his hometown finds himself
reconnecting with his 12 year old son by
coaching his pop warner football team
but we started out the interview where i
asked him about going to high school
same high school with the wwe legend
mick foley
yeah the wwe hall of famer
he was the uh heavyweight on our team
and he had no one to practice with and i
was a running back on our team and i was
a pretty big kid uh uh back then i was
in good shape and uh they needed another
heavyweight so they they brought me over
to wrestle with mick
and uh i'd never wrestled before but uh
he's such a sweet kid i knew him and
he's such a great guy
and uh i got to wrestle with him and
train with him and and kind of worked
through the season with him and it
rested one year that was it but when did
you realize that that mick foley had
become that mick foley
with wwe
just now i'm putting it together right
now just uh
as you're saying i'm like oh my gosh
this is all adding up now what is wow
wow
uh
yeah i mean i knew he was in he was a he
was a nut bag back in the day he would
he was i remember him jumping off his
roof
into boxes and he was always into that
crazy stuff and didn't seem like that it
fought like his personality he's a very
sweet guy but he was just a a nut he
would he would he would do anything he
would eat stuff and you didn't even want
to get into it it was just he was a
crazy
uh sweet heart of a guy which uh again
weird combo you know
when i don't know how this works that if
you hear there's a movie about sean
payton or somebody comes to you and says
we think you look like sean payton or
could play that role
no no sandler sammer came to me
and sent the script and said hey listen
buddy i got an idea that i think could
be a really cool sports movie
uh what do you think about this and then
he sent me the script and i once he
pitched it to me
about sean payton and the story was
about him going back to coach's 12 year
old son
i was i was in 100 i mean i loved it i
loved the idea of it all and uh yeah i
mean it was like it was a no-brainer you
know how do you fall into that coach
uh
persona
are you drawing off other coaches uh
famous coaches just go you just kind of
go with what no i don't want to do that
but i just
you start with what you think a coach is
going to be and this guy and a motivator
and let's go and then when i got to meet
sean and talk to him and
uh try to find out what he's about and
what he does specifically different than
ever you know than than other coaches
that's the hardest thing because there's
a lot of great coaches that are just
motivating and do different things and
but he's he's a fun guy man he really is
and uh
the most difficult thing for me with
with sean was the the accent because
he's from california but like he he
sounds a little text there's like
everything in there and he had admitted
it i'm like because i go i'm having a
tough time getting you down and he said
uh yeah because he goes i i switch it up
the movie is home team we're talking to
kevin james he portrays sean payton this
is two years after the super bowl win
when he was uh suspended do you remember
first late night appearance
this is mine stand up
oh yeah i mean as doing stand up or
doing like sit down with uh you know on
the tonight show i remember tonight show
was just
it was misery for me you know i was so
scared uh yeah i remember that one how
old were you uh
i was
i started to stand up at
24 or something 23. i i was probably
26 maybe some a few years later uh and
it was i was just frightened i remember
i had gotten tonight's show i was in
california
uh and there was an opening and we
wanted to you know and the comedian
works for the tonight show his whole
career that's what you're working for
that was the big benchmark
and i got it and my my uh manager called
me uh and said you got it and uh
i got panicked i was like he's like it's
this week and i'm like well i'm not
ready yet she's like what are you
talking about we're out here we're ready
to do it you've been doing stand up your
whole life you know now you're starting
to do it i go well i'm just not ready
yet because it's live it's that whole
that live with the camera and stuff like
that i don't want to do it and i get
panicked and he goes i go can you cancel
tell them i can't do it you know and you
you want to cancel and let them know you
don't want to do it you've been working
for this ho
so i said he convinced me to actually do
it and then uh he goes just go practice
your set so i run around town i went to
igb's this was a comedy club back in the
day the improv all these clubs and and
practice my set and it was the night
before the tonight show
and i i did great in front of the
audience but i said i'm still panicked
i'm afraid he's like what are you afraid
you're going to do so i remember we're
up at night me and jeff sussman my
manager up at
like two o'clock in the morning and and
he's like what are you still panicked
about i was really having a panic attack
he said i said i just i'm gonna forget
my lines and it's a live show i don't
want to do it so he started he literally
was lighting things on fire and throwing
them at me he goes do your act right now
and he just started throwing things at
me like shoes and this and that and i
was
trying to evade that and and do my act i
got no sleep that night i went to the
tonight show it wasn't with johnny by
the way it was with jay leno at the time
i didn't make it when johnny was there
uh but leno came backstage and he's like
how are you doing i had bags under my
eyes i was panicked i didn't want to do
it i said listen man i'm afraid i don't
want you know i'm nervous he's like what
are you afraid of i go i'm going to
forget my stuff and this and that and i
remember he was the greatest he's like
hey don't worry about it you know we'll
stop it we'll stop the tapes and then
and do it again i go but it's a live
show because yeah but we don't air 211
you know whatever so you couldn't you
can mess up don't you're going to be
fine we'll do everything we'll walk you
through it and it was the great he
calmed me down
and uh i got through it who who are you
mistaken for
right now does any show probably
i don't know
does that anybody come up and say aren't
you
[Music]
jason stafford
pavarotti
no
no not statham what you mean the new
look with this look what i'm going for
yeah
are you
going for jason statham look
i would love that that's actually a good
idea i don't think it's too
complementary about jason statham
but i uh
[Music]
yeah if jason statham lost everything i
guess and lived the rest of his life on
a boat
any nothing but dominoes but it looks
like you're down on your luck kev i mean
in that room there's there's nothing
in the room
like it looks kind of sad
yeah do you want me to show you around
yeah like that's i mean
do you have a people's choice award in
there or anything like that i mean no
there's no there's nothing
no
no is everything okay is everything okay
i didn't want to go into this i mean i
didn't know we were going this way with
everything but uh yeah i mean i mean
thoughts and prayers for you here i i
just yes yes
going with the minimalist life you know
i thinking less is more no furniture in
there looks like somebody's been like
kids have been scribbling on the walls
or something
does that look like scribbling
this chair doesn't even have a bottom
i'm actually just squatting right now
if i showed you yeah yeah i'm in full
sumo squat right now well the movie
comes out friday january 28th and uh you
can see kevin james be an nfl well sort
of an nfl head coach to uh to 12 year
olds it's uh called home team hey it's
great to catch up with you and uh
congrats on the movie and
thank you and thank you for your part
that's all i'm gonna say
you were great you were wonderful i
don't want to guess i understand i i was
gonna say that i was but i i'm glad you
said it i appreciate it yes
you're amazing you're amazing in the
movie i'm not even kidding i'm not even
kidding because when when we got it back
from uh editing they sent me the scene
so i'm gonna say and it's nothing
major what you're doing i'm just saying
that but you made it major which was and
i meant that i called sandler
immediately i go
this
guy's getting incredible he's getting
he's just getting better and better
honestly each movie you do you're
amazing thank you
kevin thank you
good luck
thanks bud i appreciate it that's kevin
james movie comes out tomorrow called
home team
i have a little cameo there
i don't want to say that i stole the
scene
but i have to play myself
oh i know that's the bummer